okay we are in problem problem number
nine problem nine if two times X minus 3
is equal to seven what is the value of x
well this is straightforward just solve
for x problem divide both sides by two
or actually yeah we could we could do
either way we could say this is two x
minus 6 is equal to 7 add 6 to both
sides you get 2x is equal to 13 divide
both sides by 2 x is equal to 13 over to
which the same thing at six and a half
which is the same thing as 6.5 right
let's 12 yep problem 10 point P lies on
the line with the equation y minus 4 is
equal to 3 times X minus 2 if the x
coordinate of P is for okay so p is the
point 4 comma what is the y-coordinate
so you know we don't know what the
y-coordinate is so we literally just
have to salt we have just input 4 for X
and then solve for y so you get y minus
4 is equal to 3 times 4 minus 2y minus 4
is equal to 3 times 4 minus 2 is 2y
minus 4 is equal to 6 y is equal to 10
that's our answer the point is for 10
but they just want to know the y
coordinate that's 10 problem 11 car a
traveled 60 miles and averaged 20 miles
per gallon of gasoline so car a traveled
60 miles and got 20 miles per gallon MPG
miles per gallon kar bhi kar be
traveled 15 miles for each gallon of
gallons okay so it got 15 miles per
gallon right it traveled 15 miles for
each gallon of gasoline it used how many
miles had car be traveled when it had
used the same amount of gasoline that
car a used to travel 60 miles so they're
saying we need to figure out how many
gallons a used and then how far can be
get with that same number of gallons
that's essentially what they're asking
so how many gallon today got used to go
60 miles one's got 20 miles per gallon
and went 60 miles so they had the car a
could do this on three gallons right the
way you can view it is gallons times
miles per gallon is equal to miles right
and so gallons will say g x 20 miles per
gallon is equal to 60 miles 60 miles so
gallons divide both sides by 20 is equal
to 30 that's x right there i'm sorry
it's equal to 360 / 23 so car a used
three gallons to go 60 miles and so car
be can go 15 miles per gallon so 15
miles miles per gallon times three
gallons three gallons equals 15 times
three is 45 gallons next problem
oops okay see if I can draw that
straight line here straight line point A
up to this point B comes down a little
bit and Point C comes down here okay
there's telling I said this is 65
degrees this is 100 degrees this is 120
and this right here is X degrees and the
figure above points ad and Eli on the
same i'm a this is a this is D this is e
they lie on the same line what is the
value of x what is the value of x so we
really just need to figure out the value
of this then we could say x is
supplementary to that so let's think
about how we can think about what the
value of this angle is so the way I
think about it is draw a line here and
you could automatically know what all
the angles in a quadrilateral are but
I'll prove it to you that all the angles
in a quadrilateral are going to add up
to 360 how do I know that because think
of it this way this angle whoops this
angle plus this angle Plus this angle is
going to be 180 and then this angle plus
this angle Plus this angle it's going to
be 180 and if you add all of those
together you're essentially adding all
the angles of the quadrat quadratic
quadrilateral it's late because this
this is equal to the angle of the whole
quadrilateral so the angles in the
entire quadrilateral or 360 degrees and
you can memorize that if you want so if
we know that all of these angles add up
to 360 degrees what is this big angle
right here well we know that 65 plus 100
plus 120 Plus let's call this angle Y
and Y is this whole thing plus y is
equal to 360 degrees and this is what
this is to 20 plus 65 to 85 + y is equal
to 3
60 so y is equal to 360 minus 2 85 and
that's what that is 75 degrees right
because 70 would be 350 right so why is
75 degrees so this this whole angle
right there is 75 and we know that X
plus this big angle here 75 and ignore
this green line i'm looking about this
big angle x plus 75 is equal to 180 so X
has to be equal to 105 degrees subtract
75 from both sides next question problem
13 the first term of a sequence is 20
and the second term is 8 so it was from
20 then it goes 28 the third term and
each term they're after is the average
of the two terms immediately preceding
it what is the value of the first term
of the sequence that is not an integer
okay so we just have to average these
two so this is going to be what it's
going to be 28 / 2 28 / 2 which equals
14 right i just took 20 plus 8 divided
by 2 this is 14 and then what's the
average of eight and 14 well 8 plus 14
is 22 so 22 divided by two which is
equal to 11 delete might work now what's
the average of 14 and 11 14 and 11 you
add them you get 25 / to that equals
12.5 so here we go this is the first
number of the series that is not an
integer 12.5 and you could fill that in
problem 14 if X is one-fifth of y so x
is equal to one fifth why why is three
tenths of Z Y is equal to three tents z
and z is greater than 0 then X is what
fraction of Z so you can literally just
substitute here right you can just
substitute this why you can substitute
310 to Z for why right because
you say y is equal to 3 10 C so x is
equal to 1 5th times why but we're going
to substitute for y 3 10 c 3 / 10 z so x
is equal to what is this 3 over 50 Z so
X is 350 it's of Z so you would fill in
3 over 50 in your answer box okay next
problem why don't know if i have time to
do it in this video or let me see let me
let me know i don't want to rush it i'll
do it in the next next video see you
soon whoops